- 'After weeks of tackling tempering...'
- Ohh!
'..panicking over petits fours and fighting filo...'
I am defeating filo!
'..those left in the Bake Off
'were back in the tent to face more gruelling challenges.'
I might as well be doing this entire challenge like this,
because that is how much of an idea I have.
'Every week the bakers were set three bakes -
'the Signature bake that showcased their personality and creative flair...'
I feel sick making this!
'..the dreaded Technical,
- 'where their intuition and baking know-how were under scrutiny...'
- Oh!
Of course, it says "bake..."
What does that mean?
'..and the Showstopper, where they had to dazzle
'and the spectacular was rewarded.
'And all this to impress our inscrutable judges,
'Mary Berry and Paul Hollywood.'
Well, these are burnt.
Overcooked. Both of them.
- Annoyingly, I really like it!
- How painful to give a compliment!
I have to say that that is absolutely beautiful.
'But once again, it's their turn to take over the tent.
'After causing havoc with breads, tarts and cakes...'
I'll get my own back!
'..Mary and Paul are back to show us their own delicious take
'on traybakes, biscuits and sweet doughs.'
The masterclass is for Mary and I to show you guys
how to bake all the bakes yourselves.
I love baking, I want you to have that passion, as well.
But the hard bit for me is baking with Mary Berry. What's she going to say?!
- Well...?
- It feels very naughty
and I'm enjoying every mouthful!
'Coming up, Mary's family recipe for ginger-spiced traybake,
'oozing with treacle and packed full of fresh stem ginger.
'Tuile - the classic French biscuit,
'creatively shaped and served with a rich chocolate mousse.
'Paul's fun recipe for a tea loaf -
'a fruit-filled giant iced bun, smothered in a rich icing.
'The apricot couronne - an enriched dough,
'filled, plaited and shaped into a sweet crown, fit for royalty.
'And Paul's irresistible brioches tetes -
'light, rich and buttery buns.
'And finally, if you ever wondered how to make your own sourdough or churn your own butter,
'Mary and Paul will show you how with their quick tips.'
The aim is to do everything in great detail
so, at home, everybody will be able to recreate what's been done on the Bake Off.
'In week five of the Bake Off, it was time for traybakes and biscuits.
'Mary set a Signature Challenge
'that gave the bakers an opportunity to show off their precision,
'prowess with flavour
'and their own distinct baking personality.'
For this Signature Challenge,
we'd like you to make your favourite traybakes.
This could be brownies, blondies, rocky roads,
and because there's a recession on, millionaire shortbreads have been downgraded to a penny crunch.
Paul and Mary have said the pieces should be identical in size
and everything you make should be from scratch.
- So on your marks...
- Get set...
- BOTH: Bake!
I'm making hazelnut and chocolate brownies.
It's something that I make often at home.
I've just pimped them up a bit, so I've added the cherries.
It's an almond sponge in the bottom,
and then it has a mixture of three berries,
which is blueberries, raspberries and blackberries.
I've got dried sour cherries, I've got some maraschino cherries just for colour.
I've also got some normal glace cherries.
Inside I'm using black cherry
and damsons, which have a good kind of fruity, berry flavour.
'But Mary's signature traybake is a spiced treacle and ginger cake,
'topped with a delicious ginger icing.'
When we gave them that challenge, it was deliberately, for us, we think simple,
but it had to be perfect, didn't it?
It had to be level, all the sides had to be uniform. It was about consistency.
I am going to do a family favourite that I've been brought up with.
It's a treacle-spiced ginger traybake.
It is delicious.
Where did this recipe come from? Is this your recipe?
This was my mother's. She made it many years ago.
What decade are we talking about?
- Or what century?
- I think she would have done this in the '60s.
- 1860s?
- 1960s!
Well, Mum died at 105...
- 1760s!
- ..and she was always a great baker.
It started off as a Victoria sandwich,
then she added some treacle to it, which gave it a real richness.
We were often given a stem ginger at Christmastime
and nobody really ate it,
so she chopped it up and put it in the traybake, and I've been doing it ever since.
I'm going to take the eggs first, put the eggs in the bowl,
because I find that if you put the eggs in the bowl,
- as you mix it, it's damp underneath and it goes in more smoothly.
- Yes.
- Four eggs, if I may.
- Four.
'Add 225 grams of baking spread.'
If you want to use butter, you can use butter, but that should be softened.
'In a separate bowl, add 300 grams of self-raising flour
'and two level teaspoons of baking powder.'
It's the all-in-one method. You do everything in the bowl and you don't mix it for long.
'Add one teaspoon of mixed spice, one teaspoon of allspice
'and 175 grams of light muscovado sugar.'
Sometimes light muscovado sugar,
- when you leave it on the shelf, it gets a bit solid.
- Yes.
So put it in the microwave,
switching it on and off on full power until it becomes soft and not lumpy.
'Pour in 200 grams of black treacle.'
- That's quite a lot, then, isn't it?
- It is, but it's good.
Don't be overgenerous with that, because if you do, it can dip.
'Then add all these ingredients into the eggs and baking spread
'and four tablespoons of milk.'
If you can take out three bulbs of stem ginger...
- Yes.
- ..and chop it really, really finely.
If you don't chop it finely,
it will sink to the bottom of the traybake.
- That's just perfect.
- Is that OK?
- Yes.
So all that remains is for me to mix that.
You could be doing this with a small hand whisk, if you prefer.
It's very easy when you get something like treacle in the mixture
- because you can see it's one colour.
- Yes.
- Shall I clear down for you, Mary?
- Lovely.
That's perfect. Now, the texture of that
is what I would've called at college "soft dropping".
Now, this I can tip into the tin, already prepared.
I've got the oven ready,
and I'm going to bake that at 160
and it will take about 35 or 40 minutes.
I've made this traybake absolutely level on top.
I don't find that a well in the centre makes it rise evenly.
- If you put it too near the top of the oven, it will rise to a peak.
- Yes.
But if you cook it lower down in the oven, you will get success.
So there we are, in the oven.
Don't be tempted to open the oven before about 30 minutes anyway,
- because it would drop.
- OK.
'It's sometimes difficult to tell when dark cake mixes are cooked.
'You'll know it's ready when the cake shrinks away from the side of the tin.'
'With time ticking in the tent, getting the bake right was proving tricky.'
30 minutes left of traybake madness.
30 minutes to go.
It's still quite soggy.
It's so difficult, because it needs to be gooey in the middle
but it needs to be cooked.
Right, OK, it's a little bit uneven, but we are where we are.
Maybe I've slightly underperformed on this
in that it might be a little bit on the simple side.
Paul, that's about 35 minutes, 40 minutes.
It's shrinking away from the sides of the paper here.
If I touch it, it springs back,
so I'll leave that in the tin to cool off
- and then I'm going to ice it.
- OK.
We want to have it a nice, shiny top of icing,
and if you can put some icing sugar in there,
about 75 grams, a bit more,
and then I mix it with the syrup from the jar.
Ah, OK.
Just take some and mix it until it's nice and smooth.
'For the decoration, you'll also need two to three bulbs of stem ginger, finely chopped.'
It's a very sticky job, this.
That traybake should be cold now. It's had about 30 minutes.
If I can have it back and I'll ice it.
There you go, Mary.
There it is, cold.
If you ice it when it's warm, the icing will run off it.
'Carefully remove the cake from the tin and peel off the paper.'
You've made me some good icing.
- I need a palette knife.
- Do you want me to drop it on?
- You put it on there.
And it really doesn't matter if it runs down the side.
- Oh, it does!
- Oh, it doesn't to me.
- I was trying to get it the right consistency for you.
- I think you've done it before.
'Completely cover the top of the cake,
'ensuring that the outer edges are as evenly coated as the centre.'
And if you get the icing too thick,
- if you dip the actual knife into hot water...
- Yes.
..it will help to spread it.
And then you take the ginger
and you just put that over the top,
as haphazardly as you like.
If you were doing it for children, you could just do a glace icing
and it'll just be a bit spicy, and you could put all sorts of sweets.
You could put a lemon icing or an orange icing on it, couldn't you?
I think orange icing would go very well.
Now, if I can have a serrated knife,
if there's one in that block there...
- There you go.
- I think it will cut, what, into about 18?
'But as the pressure of cutting the perfect slice got to the bakers...'
It's going to be difficult to get that exactly right.
180...
'..basic arithmetic became problematic.'
- HE SIGHS
- 18 by 3?
Howard, are yours four-centimetre squares?
Oh, gosh! I've done it by eye! I don't know!
This is where delicate and finesse and I part company.
Well, we never met.
There we are. We've got 18 slices.
I love that combination of that lovely ginger on top,
then the lovely smooth icing,
and you get a lovely texture inside
with flecks of ginger all the way through.
I'm very tempted to have some now,
- but we'll save it and have it with a cup of tea.
- OK.
Spiced treacle and ginger traybake,
a great family favourite of ours.
Mary, you promised I could have a piece when I got my tea.
- I've got my tea, can I have a piece, please?
- Course you can.
They look delicious. They're so...
The smell of that ginger, as well, I think it works a treat.
Got to have a cup of tea, as well.
It works so well with tea. It's moist, the ginger's in there,
that icing on the top is now dried and it tastes delicious,
and then the stem ginger comes through, as well.
- That's good, that.
- It's really like a luxury gingerbread that's turned into a cake.
Mm. Spot-on, that, Mary.
'If you've ever wondered how to make your own sourdough starter, Paul shows us how.'
This, basically, is making yeast.
You're beginning to harness the yeast, the lactobacillus is in the air.
Now, to do that, you need strong white flour, also an organic apple.
Grate it straight into the flour.
It has to be organic.
You can't have any chemicals on this at all.
That will impede the growth of the starter itself, actual wild yeast.
And then add water.
Enough to make a thick batter.
It's a bit like a pancake batter.
That's perfect. It's just falling off the spoon.
Now we need to pop that into a jar, seal it down,
get a black marker pen and just mark the level of the dough.
This will grow over the next two, three days.
It'll probably double in size, if not more.
You open it up and it'll fizz, like you just opened a bottle of lemonade.
That's perfect.
Get the dough that's in there, discard half of it.
Put it in a bowl, feed it with more flour and water,
take it back to a thick batter again and then pop it back into the jar.
You need to do that every two, three days
until the dough itself rises within 24 hours.
Once it begins to rise within 24 hours,
that is ready to use in replacement of yeast in your dough.
'A simple and successful start to Biscuit Week
'did not mean Mary Berry was making things easy.
'With no clue as to what to expect,
'she gave them a shock by setting a challenge
'that was to be the most technically demanding so far.'
- Hello, bakers.
- Today, what we're asking you to make is a French classic.
It is as French as striking, smoking and shrugging.
- We would like you to make 18 tuiles.
- Tuiles!
You've got an hour and a half to make your tuiles.
- On your marks...
- Get set...
- BOTH: Bake!
I've never made tuiles!
I'm going to follow the instructions and just pray!
I mean, what?
I'm not going in completely clueless
but about 80 per cent clueless, I'd say.
'"Tuile" is French for "tile".
'These delicate, elegant biscuits are often patterned with chocolate
'and come in all shapes and sizes.'
I'm going to make some cigar shapes,
you know, those little rolls, the classic ones that you do over a rolling pin,
and I'm also going to make a basket,
because if you make a basket, you don't need any equipment,
you can just do it on a baking tray.
If you can get 200 grams of softened butter...
I'm going to mix that with 180 grams of icing sugar,
so they can both go in this bowl.
Don't sieve the icing sugar, because we're giving it a good beat.
I'm going to add a teaspoonful of vanilla extract.
You could use vanilla paste if you've got it
or scrape out the seeds straight out of the vanilla pod.
The choice is yours. Whatever you've got in the cupboard.
'Mix until you have a smooth paste.'
I'm trying to get icing sugar not over you and me!
I wish you were wearing your navy blue shirt. I'd have got it!
'Then separate out six large eggs, discarding the yolks.'
Of course, we could use those egg yolks up
to make something like lemon curd.
A good omelette.
A very rich omelette, if I might say.
A Sunday morning omelette - you can't beat it.
Now, we need to slacken down that,
only enough to blend it.
I've now got to add the egg whites.
Start very slowly.
'Then weigh out 200 grams of flour and add it to your mixture.'
It's important not to overwork the mixture.
There's a happy medium between overworking and getting all the flour incorporated.
If you do overmix that tuile mix,
what could happen to the tuiles?
They'll shrink. And we don't want them shrinking.
'For the chocolate decoration,
'take one sixth of your mixture and mix it with three level teaspoons of cocoa.'
So there's the chocolate mixture and there's the tuile mixture.
If those can just go in the fridge
to chill for about 15 minutes, 20 minutes...
'Chilling helps the fat in the mixture set,
'making it easier to shape and pipe.'
So, Paul, those mixtures should've thickened up.
They've had about 15, 20 minutes in the fridge.
'Mary's using a special template for her tuiles,
'placed on a baking sheet, on top of a baking parchment.'
You can take the top of an ice cream lid,
cut round with sharp scissors and make it flat,
and then make circles like this,
and you'll get four on an ice cream lid.
I'm going to do the next one down. Spread it across the top.
You can go several times until you get it absolutely level.
I'm really going for an effort to make it really thin.
'Getting the level wrong can result in a biscuit
'that's too thick to get a good snap,
'or one that's too fragile to shape...'
It's getting them thin enough without being too thin.
'..something the bakers were struggling to get right.'
These aren't tuiles, these are paper!
That's definitely not thick enough.
There's a real knack to it, a knack which I...
do not have!
We need to lift this off in one upright movement. There we are.
Now, let's make some of them chocolate.
So you take the piping bag
and then turn it back
and push that right down.
The amount of cocoa, we said three teaspoons,
just enough to get it this nice colour.
Shall I do one,
and then I bet you'll speed up and do them like lightning.
If they're a bit wiggly and it doesn't look perfect
and you're doing it at home, at least you know it's home-made.
It's really giving yourself time to do something like this.
Don't do it in a hurry, because it does take time,
it takes care.
Right, we cook those at 160. That's set.
If you can pop those in and we'll just keep an eye on them. About five minutes.
I shall be standing here at four.
'While the classic tuiles are baking, make your free-form basket
'by spreading a very thin layer of tuile paste directly onto baking parchment
'and shape it into a rough circle of about eight inches.'
Now, that'll take, again, anything from about four minutes upwards. Keep an eye.
When the edge of that is just a light brown colour, take it out.
How are those doing there?
Just a tinge of colour.
So it's just the happy medium of getting them out
that you can just get your hands on them. Let's just have a look.
Let's lift these off. They've kept their shape beautifully.
Just gently mould them over like that.
You've got to be quick.
'If they cool down they go hard, making them impossible to shape,
'as some of our bakers found out.'
They dry really quickly when they come out the oven! Ah!
Oh, gosh! This is really hard.
This is really hard.
Some of these are, erm,
a bit more like fag butts than cigars.
'To soften them up again, pop them back in the oven for a few seconds.
'At home, make smaller batches to ensure they can be quickly shaped straight from the oven.'
And then the cigars...
Let's try again with these. They've become soft.
Pinch it over the top there and then roll round,
and you can go on doing this.
Keep that underneath.
I'm going to try a wooden spoon.
Just put that over. I've run out of rolling pin.
- Anything round.
- Vodka bottle?
A bit too big.
Anyway, I haven't got a vodka bottle in my house.
- Gin.
- They're the wrong shape.
So we'll put them on a rack to cool. I certainly like your idea of doing it on a wooden spoon.
Let's dip the ends in some melted chocolate.
Do it one at a time and leave it on the rack there.
You do one of yours.
- As always, a very generous amount of chocolate.
- Of course.
- My cigarillo is not going to be upstaged by yours, Mary.
- All right.
'While the chocolate dries, shape your basket.'
It's getting a colour around the outside.
'Gently mould the hot biscuit over the top of a jar, tin or bowl
'and let it cool.'
In the basket, I'm going to make a rich, indulgent,
very naughty mousse.
For that, I need 300 grams of pouring double cream.
'Pour half the cream into a pan, reserving the rest for later.'
I'm going to turn that on and make it very, very hot,
not boiling, but very, very hot.
'Then break up 200 grams of chocolate.'
I always use about a 40 per cent chocolate.
You can use one with a 70 if you like.
This has now come to a piping hot.
Drop that chocolate in there.
That's it.
'Stir the chocolate until it's completely dissolved into the cream.'
Right, that's absolutely perfect. Look at that.
- You see?
- Yes. No lumps.
No lumps of chocolate, you see? Perfect.
I've got to chill that now, so in that goes into the bowl.
Gosh, rich and indulgent!
But why not, every so often?
So that's ready to be put to one side to get cool.
It'll only take about ten minutes.
Then, to make it a little bit light,
- I'm going to add whipped egg whites.
- So it's a classic mousse.
- It is.
'Whisk one egg white until it forms firm peaks.
'Then add 50 grams of sugar, a spoonful at a time,
'until you have a soft meringue.'
That should've cooled. It has.
And I'm going to slacken that down with the pouring double cream.
'Once the remaining cold cream is fully incorporated,
'carefully fold in your meringue.'
You don't want it to be streaky.
Get right down to the bottom of the bowl.
That's it.
So that doesn't need to be covered with anything. It doesn't get a skin on top.
'Then put in the fridge to chill.'
Now, I suppose you could pipe that,
but I don't think I would bother to get out a piping bag,
and I like the informality of spoons.
So let's just take some out
and just drop it in here.
- Oh, it's lovely!
- Good mousse, that.
Two scoops would be about right.
Actually, it's rather a lot, but why not?
I'm going to put three raspberries
and I'm going to put a sifting of icing sugar.
It's so delicate and special.
So all from the same mixture, we've got a real variety.
Tasting time!
I'm going straight for this one in the front.
I hope it's got a good snap.
- Perfect!
- Try it, Mary, and tell us what you think.
Oh!
Crisp, crunchy, full of flavour.
Lovely combination of the chocolate.
I'm going to go with the chocolate one on this one,
with the mousse, obviously!
I'm not going to be left out. I'm dying to try the mousse.
Mm!
The addition of the chocolate with the mousse with these...
- And what a crunch!
- It's a winner.
'Week six of the Bake Off and Paul was back in charge,
'but unperturbed by this,
'the bakers were looking forward to a Signature bake
'that allowed them to bring their personality and creative flair
'to a classic British tea loaf.'
Hello, bakers. You can make any loaf you like.
It could be the Welsh bara brith - apologies for the pronunciation - or the barmbrack from Ireland,
or - my own favourite - the Croydon cob,
which also doubles up as a weapon for close hand-to-hand combat.
Paul and Mary would like you to use yeast.
Any other ingredients are up to you.
- So on your marks...
- Get set...
- BOTH: Bake!
This is sort of like a Chai latte.
It's a spiced Indian tea drink, flavoured with cinnamon, cardamom and ginger.
I like to do signature bakes that are true to me.
I think Mary would've been a little bit upset and disappointed if I wasn't going to make bara brith.
There are so many flavours and spices and food experiences out there
that I kind of want to try them all.
'For Paul's signature tea loaf,
'he is making a fruit-filled giant iced bun.'
We used to go to a bakery when we were kids, about 13, 14,
and it wasn't even my dad's, it was another guy's bakery,
but we used to buy this loaf and it was a massive iced bun.
You need to make the base dough first.
Could you weigh me up 400 grams of strong bread flour, please?
Yes.
I'm putting a teaspoon and a half of salt in there, which is about seven grams,
and I've also got some fast-action yeast.
That goes straight in, ten grams to the other side of the bowl.
At this stage, what I'm doing is keeping the yeast and the salt apart from each other.
'Then add 40 grams of caster sugar
'and 40 grams of butter.'
I've also got something which is used a lot in enriched doughs - milk.
120ml of milk and 120ml of water.
You can use all milk if you want,
but the addition of the water slackens the dough and prevents that...
we call it retardation of the yeast.
All the milk goes in there, half the water,
and get your hands in there, like a claw.
Just turn it round.
'Keep adding the water until the flour is incorporated
'and you have a soft ball of dough.'
I'm going to manipulate the dough slightly by rolling it up.
Heel of the palm, fingers...
..folding it, rolling it up all the way,
building up the gluten levels in the dough.
The impact of the sugar, what it does is, it feeds the yeast,
but it tends to break it down so you've got to be careful.
You've got to really work the dough to get the glutinous strands built up.
Strengthen them, basically.
What the sugar takes away, your energy needs to get into it
and get it going and build up that strength in it.
OK, Mary, see how smooth that is now.
- There you go, Mary.
- It's totally changed texture.
It's beautifully smooth, no loose flour.
We'll leave that to rest for at least half an hour to an hour.
Nice, smooth dough, full of gluten, it's got the protein, the yeast is beginning to activate.
Pop it in the bowl, cover it up with prove wrap
just to prevent a skin getting on it, that's all.
'Prove the dough at room temperature for about an hour.'
Gosh, that's grown a bit.
What we need to do now is add the rest of the ingredients.
'Weigh out 50 grams of sultanas and 60 grams of glace cherries,
'then mix into these a teaspoon of cinnamon.'
Don't put it straight into the dough.
You'll get a more evenly distributed flavour if you coat the fruit rather than the dough.
'Then grate in the zest of three large oranges.'
I love the flavour of orange in this.
Of course, you could always use these oranges up afterwards
in a nice orange salad.
- Yes.
- Slices, with a bit of Cointreau and sugar.
- Fruit salad.
- Vodka...maybe?
- No!
You need to incorporate that fruit - the cherries, the oranges - in,
so you get the dough on the outside and you push it in.
It's very elastic at this stage, isn't it?
It's been resting, you see, so it's got air in it
and all the gluten's there, the stretch is there.
Once you've got your fruit in there, bring it out.
That's your dough done. You need to shape your dough.
The way they used to do it in the bakery down the road
was like a torpedo sort of shape, you know?
So what I'm going to do, flatten it down,
fold it over, knuckles in,
fold over the top and then shape.
Tighten it with your fingers at the back...
so you end up with one line down the middle, smooth on the top,
tapered both ends.
Onto the tray...
Pop it in there.
'Cover the dough in a plastic bag
'to give the dough space to rise and stop a skin forming.
'Prove it at room temperature for an hour
'or until it's doubled in size.'
Look at this. This has been rested for just under an hour.
Let me bring it out and show you. You can see how big it's got.
It's absolutely massive!
It's lovely and soft, very light.
It bounces, it's like a jelly.
My oven's set at around 220.
- That's very hot.
- Bread bakes at a high temperature.
It'll go in for about 25 minutes and it'll go a nice dark colour.
Because of the sugar and butter in there, it will colour. Do not panic about the colour.
Leave it in there for a minimum of that time,
otherwise it's still going to be doughy inside.
'But back on the Bake Off,
'it wasn't just timing that caused problems.'
I've got a loaf in there that doesn't look very attractive at the moment.
- I think it looks nice!
- It's a northern tea loaf that's a bit on the, er,
rough and ready side!
Hm... I could cry.
- Oh, why?
- It's gone wrong.
- Why?
- It should be higher than that.
- Should it?
I think mine's spread.
It's gone...
Here's our loaf. It's been out for an hour, it's nice and cool.
To finish it off, which is a bit unusual,
we're going to turn it into a massive iced bun.
I need icing sugar and water.
'You'll need around 75 grams of icing sugar to cover the loaf.'
The trick is when you're mixing icing sugar -
always start off with a little bit.
Get your hands in there.
- A little drop.
- A little bit more, always a little at a time.
I suppose you could use some of that orange juice if you wanted to.
- You could.
- Because we've used the zest.
What happens if the doorbell goes?
"Hello?" Or "hello".
- You always leave one free, Mary.
- OK.
Again, that's nicely mixed in now, it's nice and smooth,
- and it's ready to go on the loaf.
- Just keep it there.
- High-five?
- I'll clean my hands now.
- I think that might be a good idea.
Put your icing on it. Let it all drip down.
Think of it on a massive iced bun.
So you just slice it and have it with a bit of butter.
So just ice it right round the outside.
Just try and take it down the side a little bit.
You don't want to cover all of it, you just want to cover the crown.
Now, you see, that looks like the loaf I used to buy
when I was a teenager!
It sets quite quick because it's a cool loaf.
- You serve it sliced?
- All you do is leave that to set.
Once it's set, slice all the way down,
bit of butter on it, cup of tea, job done -
the perfect enriched dough.
I can't wait to see that sliced straight through the cherries.
Lovely.
I'm going to cut you a slice of this, OK?
See the structure inside? It's lovely, innit?!
That looks lovely. And I can see a cherry coming through there.
Now, if I cut this in half...
I can see the flecks of orange through there.
I've been a bit generous with the butter, but why not?
Well...?
It feels very naughty and I'm enjoying every mouthful!
Isn't it like a massive iced bun?
Well, it's an iced bun with a lot more interest in it -
the cherries and the fruits, the raisins inside.
Absolutely delicious! And lots of icing!
- Such a treat.
- Thanks, Mary.
'Now, Mary's special tip
'on how to make your own butter...'
I'm going to make something that I'm quite sure you've never made before. I'm going to make butter.
To do this, you simply overwhip double cream.
So full speed ahead until it turns
and you notice a sort of cloudy liquid coming out.
It's past the piping stage, it's solid,
but I'm just waiting for the separation.
We're nearly there.
There it is. We've got butter.
Now to strain it,
because the buttermilk is not a flavour that you want.
So just shake that to begin with to get some of that buttermilk out,
and then you squeeze it
until you get as much out as you can.
So then run cold water through that.
So all the buttermilk is washed out of that
and the next process is to just put it in a cloth again
and squeeze it so you get all the water out.
Then you've got butter! I've got some just at that stage.
Let's see what we've got inside here. Home-made butter.
At this stage, you could add salt to it.
If you want to be very French, you can add some coarse salt to it.
It's really, I think, so good
and a real treat.
Mm. All that's missing is a nice dollop of marmalade.
It's really good
and I haven't wasted that last carton of cream that I might have thrown away.
Mm!
'As always, the terror-filled Technical
'saw the bakers attempting to second-guess Paul.
'He chose a French loaf that was technically tricky,
'with an alarming level of detail and clever use of flavours.'
The Technical Challenge is...
an apricot couronne, OK? A traditional French sweet loaf.
We need enriched dough, apricots,
twisted and formed into a crown.
- You have two and three quarter hours to bake it. So on your marks...
- Get set, bake.
I think it's like a twisted, sort of rounded thing.
I think you do it a bit like a Swiss roll or a Chelsea bun and you split it in half.
I might as well be doing this entire challenge like this,
because that is how much of an idea I have.
'This beautiful, traditional celebration bread, stuffed with fruit,
'is a long-time favourite of Paul's.'
I'm going to show you how to do it myself - properly.
- Right!
- In fact, I'll mix this one by hand, I think.
Can you weigh up for me 250 grams
of strong white bread flour, please?
- 250 grams.
- Thank you, Mary.
Here we have our key ingredients again -
the salt for flavour, the yeast for the rising.
'Add five grams of salt
'and seven grams of yeast on separate sides of the bowl.
'Then add 50 grams of softened butter, one egg,
'and, bit by bit, 105 millilitres of milk.'
What I'm going to do is begin to crush the butter down into the flour,
break up the egg in there, as well. You could do this in a mixer if you want.
Gently twist the dough around, trying to pick up all the flour.
I've still got some more milk to go.
Now, we've already got a ball of dough here.
So a bit of flour...
Again, I'm using flour because it's got eggs in.
It's an emulsified dough, it's got lots of butter in there,
and all I'm going to do is manipulate that dough
until it becomes nice, soft and elastic.
'Knead your dough for around ten minutes.'
While I'm doing this, would you mind chopping up into small pieces
120 grams of the apricots?
Now, what I've got here is my dough
that's nice and soft and already elastic.
All I'm going to do is pop that into a bowl,
cover it in a tea towel,
just to stop the air from getting to it too much.
'And then set aside to prove.'
- Is that about what you want?
- That is pretty much perfect, Mary.
I've got some orange juice. Because these are dried anyway,
a little bit of juice just soaks that down a little bit.
I'll leave these to soak for a minute.
Is that fresh orange juice or the sort in a carton?
You can use any juice, to be honest, but orange works well in this.
'Leave the apricots to soak for 20 minutes,
'then add to them 90 grams of softened butter,
'70 grams of muscovado sugar
'and 35 grams of plain flour.'
This is a slight thickener with the flour.
It's just to bring all the ingredients together.
'Add the zest of an orange, 60 grams of raisins
'and 65 grams of walnuts.'
That's basically the filling for the couronne.
There's a lot going on in there, you know. It's gorgeous.
Bring back your dough, get some flour onto the bench.
Look at that. See that air that's got in it already.
It's bouncy, it's light.
- And immediately you touch it, it drops down again.
- Yes.
So to make the couronne, you need to stretch this out.
So what you're going to do is roll out the dough.
It looks positively alive. It keeps drooping back again.
It will do. It'll stretch and then pull back on itself, but that's about right now.
What you want to do is just tack...
..the end of the dough to the table, as if you're making a Danish pastry.
So, you're doing it like an eight-strand plait,
- pressing it down, the dough on the table?
- No.
It's more like a Chelsea bun or a Danish pastry.
OK. I'm not going to argue with you. Get on.
OK, so we've got our dough. We can get our filling.
What I'm going to do is tip that onto here,
like so...
And then I've got a palette knife. Spread that out.
'Make sure your filling is perfectly even across the whole rectangle.
'That's if you've understood what a rectangle is...'
So it just says, "Roll out the dough into a rectangle."
"Roll up the dough and then cut it in half."
How do you roll it up and cut it into two?
Do you roll it that way?
Am I reading this right? Oh, gosh!
Near enough a rectangle to me.
Then it says,
"Spread the apricot mixture over the dough."
It's all guesswork! SHE LAUGHS
Right, now you've got to roll it up,
- like you do, you know when you break the back of a roulade?
- Yes.
- A bit like a Chelsea bun.
- Yes, it is.
What you do is, you roll it up,
keep that tacked down there so you've got some tension on it...
- ..and then roll it up.
- Right.
Tack all the dough so it's all joined together.
This is very thin, this dough.
You begin to roll it out a little bit,
put a bit of pressure on there.
And then just trim off - let's take that -
square off the ends slightly.
What we're going to do is cut it right down the middle,
all the way...
- ..like so.
- Right.
Then you need to open the guts of it up.
Likewise with this one.
Each end - grip and then twist.
Bring it round, underneath
and then force it together.
There is your couronne.
That then goes onto...
..a baking tray
and is left to prove up for about 40 minutes.
'But as Glenn and Howard found out, timings may differ.'
Ooh, 'ello! That's a crown and a half.
It's a bit big, isn't it? Yeah.
I've just seen Howard's!
It's not big enough. Howard's is like twice as big!
- How long have we got left?
- That's what it should look like.
- How long have you got left?
- I don't know because I don't know how long I need.
I wanted to see something different.
It sounds harder than it is.
- It's just a Chelsea bun, by any other name.
- Yeah.
Truly.
There it is, Mary. This guy's been resting.
- See the size of that fella now?
- It's sort of puffed up, hasn't it?
Now, it's set for 200 again, that's 180 fan.
It's going to go in for about 25 minutes.
Let the smells begin!
There we have it, Mary, the cooled couronne.
Beautiful colour. Nice, rich brown colour all the way through.
The black spots are just where the sugar's come through.
Now, there's three things I'm going to add to this.
- The first is warmed apricot jam.
- Is it sieved?
- It is sieved.
You can buy masking glaze professionally.
I know you can buy it in some stores, as well.
I don't even mind if you put ordinary apricot jam over, with little bits. I hope I get the bits.
Well, there's so many bits inside, why not?
Loads of apricot jam, which just soaks into the dough.
- It comes alive when you put that shine on.
- It's like varnishing it.
The next thing I'm going to add is 200 grams of icing sugar,
with 27, 28ml of water, that's it.
Be quite loose with this. Try and be quite arty with it.
- It's the informal finish.
- Yes. I love this. I love this bit.
You want it to be white, you want it to show up, you know?
You want it to look attractive.
It's zigzagged roughly all over the top.
The last thing I'm going to add, I've got some flaked almonds here.
Just crush them lightly and then just drizzle that...
around the top.
And there you go - a loaf that's fit for any festival.
It looks wonderful for any occasion.
I love the finish you've got there.
It's sort of informal, but very special.
I'll cut a wedge and I'll give you...give you a chance to try some.
- Look at all that filling in there.
- You packed so much filling in,
I was wondering whether it would all come out, but it's kept in very well.
It's absolutely packed with apricots and nuts, layer upon layer,
and then that lovely finish of icing and nuts.
It's all so tempting.
That is wonderful. I was thinking, "We ought to put butter on it," but you couldn't possibly.
There is so much fruit, so much flavour in there,
it's just perfect as it is.
One thing you can taste in the apricots
is that orange juice which it was soaked in.
There's a lot of zest in there, as well, which comes through in the dough.
I think it's delicious. It's such a great loaf.
'Now Mary's quick tip on how to give your butter a boost
'with fresh herbs.'
These are fresh chives.
Get them into a tight bunch
and then just chop them.
This is salted butter.
I like to put a little bit of pepper in there.
Soften it down to begin with so it's workable,
and then add all the chives in there, like that.
So there it is.
Make sure that it's evenly through the butter.
And I'm using ice cube trays. This is a silicone, flexible one
and that means it's easier to get out.
So take a spoon
and put spoonfuls into the ice cube tray,
like that...
..and then flatten it down right to the edges.
If you were doing a lot, you could put it in a piping bag and it would be much quicker.
And this amount is just the amount
to perhaps put on the top of a steak or on fish,
so it's very handy to have.
So I'll put those in the freezer,
and I've got some all ready there.
So these are the ice cubes.
Another way of doing it is to do it - you can tell it's frozen! - in a sort of sausage shape
and then you just untwist the clingfilm and cut slices off.
Maybe there's four of you for supper, four slices,
then put what you don't use back in the freezer.
'Mary and Paul wanted our bakers
'to create something special for the sweet dough Showstopper -
'European sweet buns.
'With a whole continent of delicious bakes to choose from,
'they could really show off.'
Now, bakers, normally we'd of course send you home to bed with no supper,
but it's sweet dough week and we know that these take time,
so we're going to set you off on your Showstopper Challenge right now, this evening.
We need you to make two different varieties of European sweet buns.
You've got 30 minutes to start your dough,
and that's in advance of a four-hour bake tomorrow.
- So on your marks...
- Get set...
- BOTH: Bake!
Tomorrow, I'm making a couple of Scandinavian buns.
When I was thinking about flavours, I wanted something rich.
I just thought, "Let's use a bit of booze."
I'm making peachy buns.
The peachy buns have got pieces of peach inside,
wrapped in a marzipan.
You can't always be good in life. You've got to go naughty sometimes.
Hopefully, it'll have a good night!
'Paul's decided to make one of France's best-loved sweet breads -
'the famous brioche tete.
'He's going to show us just how easy it can be to make it at home.'
I'm going to show you how to make a brioche tete.
- Could you weigh me up 500 grams of strong white bread flour, please, Mary?
- All right.
We gave the option to the bakers of using half an hour the day before to prepare the dough.
I'm going to be using a mixer, because to make a brioche
you need to mix the dough and then add all the butter at the end.
So overnight, we chill it down, the butter hardens
and then you can shape it into whatever way you want.
- Is that 500?
- Exactly.
- Thank you.
Can I have 50 grams of caster sugar, as well, please, Mary?
Sugar's integral in brioche.
It's inherently a very sweet dough.
'To this, add seven grams of salt and ten grams of yeast.
'Then add 140 millilitres of milk and five eggs.'
It's a lot of eggs. It's nearly an egg to every 100 gram of flour. That's a lot.
We start the mix off.
Mix this together and form a paste. Let it become glutinous so it becomes stretchy.
Leave it in there for about five minutes to develop the dough.
'If you're making the dough by hand,
'you'll need to mix it for around eight minutes to get the same results.'
That's coming together nicely now.
Now it's beginning to bind together as a lump,
you just turn it up.
- It's hard work, this baking, isn't it?
- I'm pleased to see you using a machine!
It's not ready. You can still see the mottled effect of the dough inside.
It's beginning to stretch now, see? But it's breaking apart too quickly.
What we're trying to do is get that to be really smooth,
so we're going to mix it a little bit longer.
The more you work it, the smoother and softer and elastic it gets.
OK. See how soft that is now and stretchy?
I've been mixing that for about six minutes
and it's ready now for the butter to go in.
Pass me the butter, please. There's 250 grams of softened butter going into this.
- All that?
- Yes. So it's basically a whole block of softened butter.
It goes right in there, right in the middle of the dough.
What we're going to do is incorporate that butter.
'Mix for another six minutes, or ten minutes by hand,
'until you have smooth and silky dough.'
Have a look at that. See how glossy it's gone.
That dough is soft, smooth, shiny, but you can't work it, look.
- It sticks to your hand.
- It's a lump. You could never mould that.
- No.
So to counter that, we pop it in the bowl.
You can see how lovely and glossy this is, and stretchy. It's perfect brioche dough.
If you just wrap that up for me, please.
Now that needs to go into the fridge overnight,
or for a minimum of eight hours, just to harden that butter.
It will rise the dough slightly in the fridge,
and it will ferment, so it will give it more flavour, as well.
Obviously, we'll be able to use it, because at the moment it's a mess.
- So are you, so get washed.
- Exactly.
- I'll put this in the fridge.
- Thanks.
'Having had the night to prove their dough, the bakers returned to the tent.'
I needed it to kind of double in size.
It has, although it's a little bit, I think, too cold in that fridge, actually.
'This was a real opportunity to show off their baking
- 'and mastery of flavours...'
- I'm happy with it.
'..with everyone making something different.'
I can't get it out!
It's wedged in.
It did look a little bit rough when I took it out of the fridge.
It looks as if it had a bad night, but, er, it should be OK.
- That's risen!
- It rises a lot.
What you've got is that hard dough, which now we can manipulate.
What we've got here is six brioche moulds.
Now, each piece you need to roll out.
You can manipulate this dough now. You couldn't do yesterday, because it was like liquid.
- It would stick to your hands yesterday.
- Precisely.
Cut off the equivalent...
It works out at 50 grams, 50 grams per ball.
Now, each piece needs one small piece,
which is the little tete - or head - on the top, and the main body of it.
So you rip off roughly about six.
So you've got your dough, make a cage
and then move it very quickly in the flour and it smoothes it off.
OK, likewise with this one -
little bit of flour, spin it round, and there it is.
Push down a little bit on the top, and it will get sticky anyway,
take your little piece, pop on top so it looks like a cottage loaf.
That then goes inside the mould... over there.
You don't have to butter the moulds because they're lined and nonstick,
and because there's so much butter in it, it's almost self-greasing.
These need to prove up now. It's a slow prove.
That's got butter in it, so you need to rise the dough,
but at the same time not melt the butter.
Leave it at an ambient temperature.
Again, grab a bag,
give a little bit of gap for them to grow.
Those will rise for half an hour to an hour,
depending on the temperature of your kitchen,
and then we'll pop them in the oven, but for now, we'll leave them alone.
- Are you waiting for them to rise to the top of the tin or...?
- They'll grow to just below that.
They've got a lot of growing to do. They'll at least double in size.
- So we leave them right here on the worktop?
- Yes.
- We can go and have a cup of tea.
- Come on.
Let's go and have a game of darts, Mary.
'Leave to prove at room temperature
'for around 45 minutes.'
You can smell the butter.
These are really soft and light.
Touch them really lightly, because see how delicate they are?
What I'm going to do is egg-wash them.
Brush it well on the top and on top of the head.
Do you have to be very careful not to drop that wash down the side?
You can see that I'm staying on the top,
- because what happens is... Very clever, Mary!
- I know.
..if you get too much egg wash down the side,
the dough then bonds itself to the inside of the mould.
- And we won't get it out!
- We won't get the thing out, correct.
That's ready to go in the oven. It's set at 200, or 180 fan.
In they go.
I'm happy with those, but those are monsters so...
- How beastly are they?
- Very.
There's going to be no panic.
Who am I kidding?!
Oh, no! That was a crap idea.
Look at those, Mary.
They look absolutely perfect!
I'm going to take these out of here. They should come out quite easily.
They're a bit hot.
You were pretty careful about not letting the egg wash go down onto the tin,
because they wouldn't come out then so easily.
It's classic brioche tete, served at breakfast time,
cut and toasted.
That is one of my favourite breakfast dishes.
I think they're just lovely just warm,
with lots more butter,
little bit of marmalade on the side, lovely!
Here you go, then, Mary, the brioches tetes.
They're a beautiful, golden-brown, buttery,
very traditional for breakfast,
- and I'd love you to try one.
- I'm dying to try one. Come on.
It's lovely and light. They're like little clouds.
I'll cut this one in half.
Look at that! Beautiful and light inside.
The smell is incredible when you first open it up.
I'll give you that one.
Now, over here, you need to have a little bit of butter on there, as well.
It just looks so soft and lovely!
Mm!
It's so good. The smell, it's just pure buttery smell.
So next time, Mary, we're getting to the final challenges,
where we've ranked them up and they've got harder and harder,
and we're going to be covering pastry, alternative
and, of course, tricky French.
I've got some very special recipes.
I'm practising like mad so I make them perfect!
Are you trying to tell me, Miss Berry,
that you actually go home and practise all the recipes for this?
I have a jolly good try!
Nonsense! You know them off the top of your head!
'Next time, Mary and Paul take on five challenges from the last weeks of the Bake Off.'
From pastry to French Week,
and even some ideas from the final programme.
'Our king and queen of cakes will guide you through their favourite Signature,
'Technical and Showstopper bakes.'
The things that we show you how to make are quite tricky,
but just bear with me and watch what I do,
because I'm trying to impart what I have learnt over the years, over to you guys.
'They'll give you all the knowledge you need
'to get perfect results every time.'
- Bit of all right!
- I'll have some more of that, yeah!
'Paul shows us how to spin pizza like a pro...
'and Mary has a handy tip to tell a good egg from a bad.
'Join us next time
'for The Great British Bake Off Masterclass.'
This gives us an opportunity to do some very special bakes
that you will be able to impress your family with in your own kitchen.
If you're that good, we'll see you on Bake Off!
Subtitles by Red Bee Media Ltd